دعني ابدا من اخر التطورات والمستجدات في
مدينه الخليل في هذه اللحظات قوات
الاحتلال تقتحم مدينه دوره جنوب الخليل
وهو الاقتحام الاوسع حتى هذه اللحظه هي
تتواجد في منطقه شارع البنوك في المدينه
تداهم منزلا يعود للمواطن شامخ النموره
قامت باعتقاله قبل قليل وهي لا تزال
تتواجد حتى هذه اللحظه داخل منزل هذا
المواطن منذ حوالي ساعه او اكثر وتجري
عمليات تفتيش واسعه في المحيط وفي المكان
اندلعت مواجهات ما بين الشبان وقوات
الاحتلال في مدينه دوه كنا نسمع بين
الفينه والاخرى اطلاق لقنابل الصوت ول
الرصاص خلال المواجهات التي اندلعت في
المدينه جنوب محافظه الخليل في مخيم
الفوار ايضا قوات الاحتلال كانت تجمعت
باعداد كبيره عند مدخل المخيم وداهمت
المخيم بعدد من الاليات العسكريه والجنود
المشاه وفتشت عددا من المنازل في مخيم
الفوار الذي يشهد منذ السابع من اكتوبر
بشكل مستمر ومتواصل اقتحامات ليليه واسفرت
هذه الاقتحامات قبل ايام عن استشهاد اثنين
من المواطنين في مخيم الفوار جنوب الخليل
بعد ان اعتلى جنود قناصه اسطح العمارات في
المخيم واطلقوا الرصاص بشكل مباشر على
هذين الشابين الذين استشهدا نتحدث ايضا في
الخليل عن اقتحام بلده بتمر الى الشمال من
المدينه تحديدا منطقه الظهر ومنطقه صافا
ما جرى هناك و ان قوات الاحتلال وبعدد
كبير من الجنود المشاه اقتحموا منازل
المواطنين وكانوا يفتشوا ويداهم منازل
المواطنين بيتا بعد بيت ويجروا تحقيقات
ميدانيه مع المواطنين في بلده بتمر شمال
الخليل التي تشهد هي الاخرى بالمناسبه
بشكل يومي اقتحامات مستمره و متواصله
خصوصا في ساعات الليل وكانت شهدت بلده
بتمر ايضا في الايام الماضيه مصادره
لمركبات المواطنين التي تقول قوات
الاحتلال بانها غير قانونيه في يطا جنوب
الخليل قوات الاحتلال
اقتحمت المدينه وداهمت منزل لاحد
المواطنين واقامت بتفتيشه تفتيشا دقيقا
وتمركزت عند منطقه رقعه تحديدا في يطا
جنوب الخليل وهي التي تشهد ايضا هي الاخرى
اقتحامات مستمره ومتواصله منذ السابع من
اكتوبر في يطا بالمناسبه ايضا هي على موعد
غدا
لتشييع شهيد من عائله الجندي كانت قوات
الاحتلال اطلقت الرصاص عليه بالقرب من
حاجز النفق في مدينه بيت لحم عصر هذا
اليوم هذا الشهيد ويبلغ من العمر 38 عاما
طبعا نحن نتحدث عن استهداف بشكل مباشر له
في منطقه منطقه حاجز النفق هو من مدينه
يطا جنوب الخليل سكان مدينه بيت لحم
الجثمان وصل من مستشفى الحسين في بيت لحم
الى مشفى ابو الحسن القاسم في مدينه يطا
جنوب الخليل غدا كما اوردت العائله سيتم
تشيع جثمانه في مسقط راسه في يطا جنوب
الخليل ما بعد صلاه الجمعه ان شاء الله
نتحدث ايضا في مدينه الخليل منطقه باب
الزاويه منطقه ق ايضا كان هناك تواجد
للقوات الاحتلال في منطقه بئر المحجر ايضا
وكان هناك تواجد في اكثر من منطقه في
المنطقه الجنوبيه في مدينه الخليل قوات
الاحتلال داهمت المنطقه الجنوبيه بعدد من
الاليات العسكريه وفتشت ايضا عدد من منازل
المواطنين بمعنى يعني ال مجمل المناطق
التي تحدثت عنها في الخليل هي متركزه في
جنوب المدينه ووسطها وشمالها نشوان وكما
ذكرت يعني هي الخليل جزء لا يتجزا من
اقتحامات تجري في هذه اللحظات للعديد من
المدن والمحافظات في الضفه الغربيه نصار
من الخليل مراسل الجزيره شكرا لك